Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
El haiku es un poema de solo 17 sílabas.
Pero ¿qué es lo esencial en un haiku?
La brevedad llama la atención,
pero el significado gira en torno a kigo,
una referencia a la naturaleza,
a la estación del año.
El haiku es una manera de observar
algo puntual en la naturaleza
y pemitir que ese detalle
nos describa a nosotros mismos
en un instante de conexión con el entorno.
El haiku es como una foto emotiva
que integramos con nuestra experiencia.
Hemos convivido estas últimas décadas
con el ruido industrial,
con la contaminación
y se discute el calentamiento global.
En los próximos diez años
entenderemos lo necesario
de una nueva sensibilidad hacia lo natural
como soporte viviente de lo humano,
como vehículo de nuestra
capacidad para percibir
lo que podemos llegar a perder
y lo que por eso ya debemos
entender, elogiar, amar.
La naturaleza es poesía por descubrir.
Aquella poesía que nos describe.
Y las nuevas generaciones
ya miran como poetas de haiku.
(Aplausos)